So just to practice a little bit more, I'm going to give you a second example.
You're trying to predict the price of a house.
Again, assume two input features, the size of the house and
the age of the house.
The house could be brand new, or older, perhaps all the way up to 40 years.
And the size in square feet might be 500, 1,000, or 1,500.
And obviously any value in between those numbers makes sense in regression.
But for the sake of this exercise I want to assume these exact numbers that I
graphed over here.
Further, I want to call size X1 and age X2, and the house price is called Y.
So, my result would be of the type Y equals some number
times x1 plus some other number times x2 plus some constant.
So let me fill in the numbers, and this example is also a little bit
contrived in that you can get an exact answer for those coefficients.
But, try to do it in your head.
And see how far you get.